the only person in this room who's
qualified to talk about football is that
man oh does he want I won a Super Bowl
bet yeah we did was it a random random
guess or you knew I knew
who was the team what was the BET was it
spread it was just who won what was it
when I was a little boy
Jesus dude
[Music]
so you guys know who Aaron Rodgers is
yep that immunized he's even immunized
right he's inoculated he's inoculated
he's one of the greatest quarterbacks of
all time brother he is what does that
mean he is going to be he is a Packers
Legend a Packer's Legend he is going to
be a New York Jet
come
wait why is he leaving Green Bay because
he didn't he I from what I saw he had
kind of a tough season he's in the
shadow of Brett Favre was he upset was
he upset with the Green Bay organization
I think there's a lot going on that that
is almost in the subtext right but we
can just see what's what's actually
happening what they're doing yeah
basically they hire they got a guy named
Jordan love a couple years ago like four
years ago they drafted him and and the
Packers were just coming off the NFC
championship game where they lost the
Niners like like and it was rough
watching that game was rough and you
could tell that the Packers needed help
at wide receiver so we're all like
wondering what they're gonna do and for
the draft we all hope that they're going
to take a wide receiver and then they
take Jordan love so that basically sends
a message to Aaron Rodgers hey we're
going to move on from you and then he
gets his like [__] fire in his belly
like Michael Jordan like like hey thanks
for dinner Mike and then Michael
Jordan's like what the [__] did you just
say to me [__]
and then he's like you
and then he said happy birthday Mike and
I said
it's on tomorrow night you know what I
mean like [__] like that so so they they
all they had to do is go to pick with
everybody and then yeah dude Aaron
Rodgers scorched Earth wins two MVPs in
a row like non-stop killing the [__]
league right so then they couldn't move
on from him yet they had to resign him
first he's too good
he proved it too well in his late 30s
and then now they're the Packers are
basically like okay you weren't that
good last year compared to how you were
before we're now ready to move on and so
now Aaron Rodgers is like [__] you I
want to show you that I [__] rock is
what I'm getting from this update so
that's underlying message underlying
message wow so I would agree with that
also the Jets are making moves for some
really good they are that he requested
for yes but like here's my one qualm
with the whole thing
is that he's from a small Market deals
with small not I mean he's obviously a
superstar but like when he comes to New
York he's going to get railed for just
doing the Pat McAfee show they're gonna
be like dude it's time to do real
outlets right real news people welcome
to the Big Show right if he sucks in
Green Bay he sucks from Green Bay you
suck in New York you get death threats
like not that it's you know like but the
Jets though the Jets the Jets suck but
like everyone's gonna be right I'm a
Giants fan so the Jets [__] suck God
but I feel like everyone hates they're
gonna be hungry but don't the giant suck
laughs
I mean I don't know we're the only team
that beat Tom Brady that's true was that
the team with plexco Burris oh yeah he's
so good he shot himself yeah yeah that's
the story The Eagles
yeah but like Broncos beat Brady who's
who's the quarter no we beat Primetime
we beat the best team in the history of
the NFL do you think so that Patriots
team I think is arguably one of the best
teams ever I think it played in the
softest division in history but that's
it's just
they still play the playoffs bro yeah
yeah I know but yeah that's why that's
why football needs to change their rules
and get rid of divisional leaders they
should change and get rid of Randy mobs
I agree
all right but giant sucks so we agree
it's all right sorry we can move on from
this one
who sucks more the Jets or the Giants
like objectives the Jets who's the
quarterback is this still Gino Smith
uh Seattle's you know he got traded yeah
I'm like who owns the Jets the uh Daniel
Jones Daniel Jones is his quarterback
yeah David dimes baby how do you feel
about that uh I think they overpaid
overpaid I think they overpaid
look he's ready to stab us he's like
what are we going to be done talking
about look the only person the only
person in this room who's qualified to
talk about football is that man oh
because he won I won a Super Bowl bet
yeah we did was it a random random guess
or you knew like you had a feeling he
just bet against him come on say you
knew say I knew who was the team what
was the BET was it spread it was just
who won what was it when I was a little
boy
here we go his sunglasses are on and
when we used to play Cowboys and Indians
I was always the Indian that's why and
that's why I'm a chief why didn't you
call me
it has nothing to do with football yes
you group of friends you are the Indian
dude you need more diverse group of
friends
the Chiefs go back to the Super Bowl
next year yes and we the boys say we're
gonna bet on the cheese he won't he
won't care what that story is yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it never happened so when whenever the
Super Bowl comes I just bet against them
he bets against the boys yeah yeah I
just it's just funny maybe I like that
stuff you're doing gambling by the way
is betting against the boys do you guys
have a good good uh you know percentage
one and one for the last two years so 50
50 not bad
that's one yeah if
you shot 50 you'd be like a top five
player in the NBA
if you did 50
exactly baseball you're a God you're the
greatest player ever
ever yeah do you guys watch baseball no
nobody watches bass I just had this
conversation yesterday and I always say
this as an immigrant family I grew up
right outside the Bronx like you were
either baseball or it was nothing but
every immigrant family nobody watched
baseball yeah why I think because they
didn't because they don't get it but
also my my family hates Cricket because
it takes a lot we watched baseball as in
the 90s though like from the movies and
in like Dodger games and then you just
stop you watch baseball movies you watch
Angels now bro no one's watching
Baseball Rookie of the Year how about
this but what but like is there
declining views for baseball well yeah
yeah but I have a theory about it which
is so Nikki my wife right she was her
dad's a big baseball nut and all this
stuff and he kind of bombed out like he
got injured and so he he wanted to go
Major League Baseball but then he had to
become a [__] tax guy instead so like
like a movie it's a little personal but
he still does baseball but he used to
make her watch baseball so [__] much
so maybe like these immigrant families
right you have to watch baseball and
then once they get free they're like I
don't have to watch baseball anymore
time consuming thing because like sit
and watch a game is
my dad's like I got mouths to feed
because yeah and like like soccer right
it's like a lot of us play as kids and
then we don't anymore as adults and then
no one watches it as an adult but it's a
worldwide crazy game yeah like the whole
world watches it yeah I don't know so
I'm like how come I don't know maybe
it's just America I do like going to
baseball games though well football's
better like we could all go to game we'd
have a great time yeah yeah but we
wouldn't stay we were just uh all right
I wouldn't care about the game that much
yeah no one's giving a [__] about the
game unless it's the playoffs that I'm
in yeah yeah playoffs in anything I'll
watch same yeah a game a game seven I
don't care what sport I'm watching like
I watch it the energy is different yeah
yeah
game seven Super Bowl yeah you know yeah
the advertising dollars on that one
forget about Super Bowl One game that's
why it's rigged that's why it's rigged
do you do you think about so like what
you're saying about the media Market in
New York yeah do you think that Aaron
Rodgers can't make it in New York no no
he can but I just don't know what his
reaction is like just being like the way
that his style is being quiet being
cryptic like in New York they'll just in
Green Bay they just want to they won't
say anything in New York they'll say
everything yeah they'll just be like
[__] you you loser or like you know
you're my God like whatever people say
that about him already kinda not not in
the world people were [__] on them
pretty big time from all my research
it's like I went on Twitter and I typed
in Aaron Rodgers as a [__] there's
[__] I guess the difference might be in
New York you're walking down the street
they're like hey [__] yeah true but
also the amount of advertising dollars
that are going to be on him I mean he's
gonna be making a lot more money period
yeah you know he'll have his Billboards
in Times Square all his where wherever
his athletic deals are how old is Aaron
Rodgers
oh man how much how much longer do you
think he has in his career Tom Brady
is Tom Brady he retired he came back
he's gonna come back though probably
every time I'm on Facebook I always see
one of those articles like he's coming
back and I'm like is this real or fake I
don't know I'm too lazy to click it but
see clickbait works
well people hate clickbait but it
[__] works and it becomes a narrative
yeah that's like made up it doesn't it's
no one is saying he's coming back no but
he is now right yeah but he is he is
according to us what if Aaron Rodgers
comes to the Jets and it's really Tom
Brady what if he balls out what if he
just goes crazy it's possible does he
does he have the team to like the pieces
to be able to like have good threats
yeah so who is who are the weapons like
Garrett Wilson
um stack defense like [__] how does that
make you feel as a Giants fan does that
make you feel like oh [__] no I don't
care because everyone knows that the
real team in New York is the Giants not
the Jets but none of you are in New York
do you hate that part I think that's
funny yeah I do think yeah it's pretty
funny they have no space for it no space
they gotta call Dolan they should play
an MSG expand Madison Square Garden
indoor let's go baby you think so it's
never gonna happen they couldn't get
it's too much money you think yeah not
enough size because MSG only fits like
what 50 000 people oh is it really oh
football stadiums are considerably
larger than basketball looks like 75
right yeah it's like 75 yeah yeah you
know how much I knew about food football
I thought the Giants were San Francisco
you're
back to baseball
paying attention during this
conversation do you think Barry Bond's
juice
I like the colors of the team perfect
[Music]
foreign